The fifth scenario that you need to be prepared for...
...is how to handle interruptions because they will happen.
It might be a dog barking, someone at the door knocking, a baby crying,..
...construction outside your window, or some unexpected technical issue.
When any of those things happen, here are some ways to handle it.
"I'm so sorry."
"You'll have to forgive the noise in the background."
"Could you come back to me in a moment?"
"I need to put myself on mute for a second."
If someone interrupts you, you can respond with:
"Sorry, let me finish my thought and then you can go ahead."
Or "One moment, please."
"I'd like to mention one more thing before we move on."
Sometimes, interruptions are caused by technical issues...
...that are completely out of our control,...
...and we may even lose the ability to stay connected to the online meeting.
In those situations, it is always a good practice to let everyone know what's happening.
You can send a message in the chat...
...to let everyone know you're having a technical difficulty...
...or if necessary, send an email.
When you do that, always let them know what you plan to do going ahead.
If you're a participant, you can let the host know that you'll review the notes.
If you're the host or the leader,...